welcome to this video and playing grow
master endless fighter wow I knew that
my score against him wasn't great but it
is really bad for out of 30 that's
pretty rotten oh yes so yeah I pre place
this line I remember let's see what we
get here get some chance to play some of
my book repertoire which I keep
forgetting I have to admit that some
some things I I wrote there i already
have forgotten when I proof read the
whole thing at the end I really once in
a while thought oh really that's a cool
line I rolled it obviously but I had
forgotten gotten most of it Oh
interesting you can really give the way
give away the pawn okay so yeah like a
pushup g7 Bishop c6 set an idea you
might have if although I can also just
go here there's nothing wrong with that
it's a bit strange giving away the sea
for porn losing lots of time in the
process okay night takes i have five
even
Jeff that's unfortunately somewhat
boring but ok it's em probably m equal
less pollution
that being said I'm is what okay night
to g3 or i don't i don't really get it
okay going to try to do something you're
on the queenside quite sure why you had
to play h three ng for him yeah that's
totally okay night d 64 is a good route
anyway so nice before you're going back
or what exactly can also do this I then
very might move I might move it I can do
this and then 9604 not c4
let's cover the beep on I can check I
have more than one good move but I think
taking here and not c4 is good checking
the beep horn so maybe as some way to
still keep this equal but it looks looks
bit uncomfortable
I can take be too and I don't really see
why I shouldn't let's take it thats
hanging it's hanging rock a one now and
you cannot go b5 unfortunately so maybe
here
hmm ok I take it Naru k 2 i've got b5
huh why not ok show me Bishop's is 6 a-6
we should be seven I mean I have group
t6 that's two points now and i have e
five I mean if everything else fails I
can go if I also why not
now it's also okay
can still play like g6 95 later
ok don't you get rid of that thing
maybe Bishop c5
so I know the beep on should go okay
might have some chicks or what maybe L
okay let's prevent 97
I have just a good technical plane I
really didn't play that well at least it
could have been done better that's
pretty sure and I'd have six even
that looks fairly passive but I don't
know what else
check no no of dumb dem shakier didn't
say that one no come on what am I doing
here this is how I lose all that game
against the sky getting getting a
complete win and then spoiling it
probably i don't remember the games okay
check
I pawn is pretty quick so I think
everyone is still ok is he threatening
something and I can do that some no made
thread check check oopsies I got some
perpetual stuff going on here can you
believe that
check I don't see how to win here it's
got this check co the check co rookie
seven and stuff that's silly but it's
down and don't see how to win him check
there's no win that sunshine would check
at least I don't yet check it's gras
Alfred yeah it's a perpetual but due to
see half-game dry thank you ah what a
sick game what is sick game ah yeah I
really like to win at least some of the
completely winning position so that I
get ya okay I'm I overlooked 2 p-7 but
of course I shouldn't even get the hell
around here this is just completely
completely lost and yeah I shouldn't
even allow this position this is the
point I could have played it in some way
that makes me win without even
calculating a single line so you cannot
screw it up now probably an overshift e6
or something king king up this is
already getting a little bit more
complicated than it is needed that it
then it needed to be check yeah he's got
some kind of ideas it's still winning
its minus 2 we after you give a chatter
engine but Jen I have success versus is
silly f5 is what the computer wants to
play of course you have he has to take
it on puzzle so on a five is better or
route d1 also wins check check yeah the
craziest thing is that check chatham
that here check that here that this is
not not that trivial actually even if it
gives me even if the comp gives minus
seven it's not that trivial because my
king is in such a bad position check so
this thought seems to win check after
that it gets tricky this is what I'm
supposed to do and here what time I
check check check I'm winning that pawn
that's of course super important and we
can take that pawn and that will win
that will win let's no perpetual now
ciao at the end it was a perpetual so I
agree to the draw even though I could
have one on time but check really really
thinks I'm silly check check what if we
had game I mean not winning it it's kind
of bad but anyway it's an interesting
ending at least ok well thanks for
watching